Ein Gefühl, als würde die Sonne aufgehen, ein Gefühl, als würden sie mich verstehen, Third Wheeling in einem Dialog von Woche zu Woche, ich höre sie, wenn ich bade, knutsche, putze oder koche. Florentin und Titzler und das Podcast-UFO, verständnisvoll und therapeutisch sowieso, und die beiden Vormagneten haben Witz und Geschick, und ich habe die Gänsehaut in meinem Limmick. Wow! Wow, wunderschön, herzlich willkommen.
Hey, eingesungen worden wie damals so, weiß ich nicht, so Künstler, so Varieté-Künstler, die dann so reinkommen. Ja, wir sind auch schon zweimal auf die Bühne gekommen und haben gemerkt, oh, das geht noch länger, oh, nochmal zurück, oh, vorne, hinten, oh, sorry, Entschuldigung. Mega. Vielen, vielen Dank an Leon, der uns hier eingesungen hat. Ich habe mir einen kleinen humoristischen Akt erlaubt, und zwar letzte Woche hatten wir Leon 2 und heute ist Leon, also da habe ich ein bisschen die Reihenfolge umgedreht, als kleinen humoristischen Einstieg, als kleine, also ein bisschen wie Zucker. Ich habe jetzt keine Lust mehr auf den Witz. Wenn so über der Waffel so ein bisschen Puderzucker einfach so das, oh, so etwas Kleines, so kleines Nettes, so eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit, dachte ich, liefere ich heute mal
den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern des
das Podcast-UFO-Podcast-Projektes.
Mensch, Stefan Augustus Maria Tietze an einer Seite.
Und Stefan.
Wie heißt du?
Wir haben darüber geredet.
Es heissen nicht alle Menschen Stefan.
Das Problem hatten wir schon, nein, das Problem
hatten wir schon oft, du kannst nicht einfach alle Leute Stefan nennen. Du heisst Stefan, nur du. Ich habe eine Zeit lang gedacht, Name, der Name ist Stefan, also ist wie so Synonym für Namen. Ja, das ist so wie, Siezen und Duzen ist Mensch und dann Stefan. Also, mit mir Stefan und dir ist... Nein, nein, ich heisse nicht auch Stefan. Florent. Genau, guck mal, da war es doch. Guck mal, ich wusste doch, dass ich irgendwo in deinem Kopf noch drin bin. Florentin Will Norek der Zweite. Genau, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid in dieser herrlichen Folge, die eingeklungen wurde von Leon. Vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank. Ist ja auch ein bisschen mein Traum, in so einem Gesangsquartett zu singen. Das war immer mein Traum, der mit diesem Was alle machen. Hast du nicht mal das Dschungelbuch gesungen? Hinten die Geier? Ich habe mal den Geierchor gesungen. Bist nicht da allein. Man muss sagen, also mein Freundeskreis besteht aus Designern und Musikern hauptsächlich. Alle sind Designer und viele sind Musiker auch. Most pretentious Satz aller Zeiten. Dafür, dass ich immer Shit bekomme für meine Hipster-Sätze. Aber ich habe mir eine Schreibmaschine geschenkt bekommen und du machst eine Folge lang. Oh Gott! Mein Freundeskreis besteht nur aus Designern und Musikern. Ja, aber auch schon immer. Meine Kindheitsfreunde sind halt ... Oh Gott! Und zwei davon waren auch gute Sänger. Dann wollten wir so ein Quartett machen, weil die gerne gesungen haben. Stellte sich raus, die beiden Musiker konnten sehr gut singen, die anderen beiden Dödel, mein anderer Kumpel und ich konnten überhaupt nicht singen, weswegen diese Proben sehr anstrengend wurden, weil ich irgendwie nicht hinbekommen habe den Unterschied zwischen Lautsprechen. Zwischen F-Moll und Fiss-Moll. Nee, für mich war Singen einfach Lautsprechen. Bist du allein? Nein, nein, du musst schon singen. Also bist du allein? Und dann haben wir den Geier-Kor gesungen, aus dem Dschungelbuch, wunderbares Lied. Seid zur Freundschaft bereit, wir sind Freunde. Seid zur Freundschaft bereit, wir sind Freunde für alle Zeit, für alle Zeit. Bisschen erinnere ich mich noch. Und das hat also das ist ja ein fantastisches Lied. Aber mega gut, richtig gut, super gut. Und dann, sag ich mal, irgendwann hat sich die Situation zugespitzt. Wir haben nämlich immer bei dem Zuhause von einem von uns geprobt, und da stand auch ein Klavier, da konnte man mir dann immer die Noten geben, so allein, allein, allein, bist du immer, war un, also einfach nur, man wollte mir einfach sagen, es ist falsch, mir hat man mir nicht den Weg gezeigt, wie man da hinkommt, sondern einfach nur falsch. Das Ziel hat man dir dann gezeigt. Genau, nicht den Weg. Und dann wollte aber noch ein anderer Kumpel zu uns kommen, ein Fünfter, mit dem wir dann den Abend verbringen und wir wollten davor noch proben. Dieser andere Kumpel hat aber die Tür nicht gefunden von dem Haus. Komisches Problem, was man, wir machen ein Gesangsquartett und ah gut, die zwei können nicht singen, ja gut, also man hat viele Probleme, sieht man schon kommen, dass jemand das Haus nicht findet oder vielleicht krank wird oder wo essen wir Mittag, manche Dinge wurden nicht bedacht. Er hat schon das Haus gefunden, aber nicht die Tür. Wo man auch merkt, es hatte vielleicht auch einen Grund, warum der nicht im Quartett war.
Aber das Lustige ist ja.
Das fünfte Rad am Wagen.
Das fünfte Rad im Quartett.
Das fünfte St nicht im Quartett war. Aber das Lustige ist ja. Das fünfte Rad am Wagen. Das fünfte Rad im Quartett. Das fünfte Stimme im Quartett, ja. Aber man muss ja mal sagen, es gab ja eine Zeit, wo es keine Handys gab, kein WhatsApp mal, wo ist eigentlich die Tür, Möglichkeiten zu fragen. Das ist wahrscheinlich, es gab Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte, viel länger als es jetzt die Möglichkeit gibt, wo das einfach ein Grund war, dass das Treffen schlicht nicht stattfindet.
Genau, ja, ich komme nicht rein. Das Burgtor ist unten. Das Burgtor ist unten. Markus Aurelius! Der Burggraben! Ich komme nicht, die Zugbrücke ist nicht unten! Und dann stehst du ja genau hinter dem Turm. Wo bleibt er denn? Also was fällt ihm denn ein, mich hier warten zu lassen? In meinem Thronsaal! Hallo! Sir, bestimmt hat er es nur vergessen. Vergessen? Das ist doch wieder einer, der will mich wieder vorführen, der will meine Macht hinterfragen. Sir, Sie haben ja so Recht. Ja, natürlich habe ich Recht. Sir, ich bin Marc Aurel in einer mittelalterlichen Burg. Natürlich stimmt alles an Ihnen, alles an Ihren. Na ja, hier und da gibt es schon kleine Feinheiten, die nicht stimmen. Nein, alles an Ihrer Existenz stimmt und ist nichts hinterfragen. In meinem Kopf haben alle alten Herrscher, haben diesen einen. Immer Grimma Schlangenzunge dabei. Grimma Schlangenzunge basically als Berater. Genau, mein Lord. Immer mit dabei. Immer jemanden mit einem Namen, wo man sagt, böse, Todeskampf. Heute das Casting für den Königsberater. Wir haben einmal Klaus. Hi, mein Name ist Klaus, ich bin 28, komme aus Hannover. Ich habe Königsberater studiert, ich habe meinen Master drin gemacht und freue mich sehr, Teil des Teams zu sein.
Dann haben wir Uwe.
Ja, ich bin Uwe, ich bin eigentlich Berufsaussteiger, also ich war lange Krankenwagenfahrer, aber jetzt keine Lust mehr gehabt und wollte jetzt mal was Neues probieren.
Okay.
Und habe Bock, habe so einen Schnellkurs gemacht, einen verbrochenen Kurs und freue mich sehr auf die neuen Herausforderungen.
Ja, und unser letzter Bewerber ist Satan Pestzunge. Hallo. Ah, du bist genau. Yes. Ja, ja, ja, ja, und du isst dann so einen Küken. Einfach beisst du dem Küken den Kopf ab. Gott, ich habe noch einen Film geguckt, wo einer einem Küken das Bein abschneidet.
Und das Küken hat, und das war, was war das für ein Film?
Lars von Trier.
Ah, okay.
Ich glaube, The House, The Jackbird.
Toller Film, eine sehr verstörende Szene, die mich bis jetzt beschäftigt, und das Küken lässt er noch nicht schreien, das war ja offensichtlich auch eine Attrappe und so, aber in der fiktionalen Welt war das ja die Erzählung. Der schneidet dem Küken das Bein ab. Und das Küken hat nicht geschrien, wahrscheinlich, weil es nicht schreien würde. Schreien ist ja so ein menschliches Ding. Aber was man erwartet ist, bist du bescheuert, mir das Bein abzuholen? Also so eine menschliche Reaktion. Genau, sag mal, hackts! Ja, kommt nicht. Gar nicht. Und das hat es noch viel schlimmer gemacht. Manchmal, weißt du, das kontraintuitiv, eher natürlich zu erzählen, das war ganz, ganz schlimm. Sorry, sorry, dass ich euch allen dieses Bild jetzt ohne den befriedigten Teil, wie, also ohne den befriedigten Teil der Fiktion und Erzählung, ihr kriegt einfach nur dieses horrific kleine Detail jetzt erzählt. Küken frittiert, lecker. Küken roh, Lars von Trier. Ja, genau. Also, wenn ihr überlegt, gehe ich zu KFC oder gehe ich zu Lars von Trier, gehe nach Trier, wo ich einfach rohe Raben und Küken essen kann, ihr wisst, was ihr machen müsst. Ihr wisst, was ihr machen müsst. Nur um diese Geschichte abzuschliessen. Wir hatten diesen Quartettübungstag und dann
kam der Freund, der die Haustür
nicht gefunden hat, also kam er durch
den Garten. Also ist er über
den Gartenzaun geklettert und kam
über den Garten. Hat so vor etwas Eindringling-Mässiges.
Über die Hintertür und es war
nachts, es war stockdunkel und wir haben
im Wohnzimmer geprobt. Für
alles.
Für alle Zeit. Und dann tauchte plötzlich dieser Freund an der Fensterscheibe auf vom vom Hintereingang vom Garten. Wir haben uns so hart erschrocken, dass einer von uns das Metronom vom Klavier geschmissen hat und dann haben wir gesagt, kommen wir lösen das Quartett auf. Das war der Punkt, wo das Quartett aufgelöst wurde. Also da haben wir gesagt, nee, dann lassen wir es. Weil wir uns so vor dem fünften Freund erschrocken haben, dass wir das Metronom... Ja, oder weil ihr kein Metronom mehr hattet. Weil mit einem Metronom steht und fällt so ein Quartett. Aber das war so ein bisschen so, hey Leute, das geht hier gerade in eine völlig falsche Richtung, wer weiss, was wir noch alles zerstören, wenn das jetzt schon das Metronom kaputt gegangen ist. Wir sind eine schwierige Gruppe. Wir sind vielleicht einfach nicht füreinander gemacht, die ersten Bruchstücke liegen schon am Boden, lasst uns aufhören, bevor es noch schlimmer wird. Das ist ja unglaublich lustig, aber auch, was der Typ dachte, der dann zu spät kam, die Haustürnich-Modus, der für die Haustönig-Modus. Ja, absolut. Der für den ganzen Abend einen schweren Stand hat. Übers Gartentörchen klettert oder durch die Hecke geht, einfach, was auch immer sehr lustig ist, man kann einfach durchhecken, durchgehen. Hecken sind nur ein mentales Hindernis, denkt da immer dran. Wenn ihr eine Hecke seht, denkt daran, es ist nur in meinem Kopf ein Hindernis. Jeder Mensch kann durch Hecken gehen, wie Homer Simpson. Er geht durch die Hecke durch, ist gebrannt, mag er, hat er dann so Äste und sowas, ist schon viel zu spät, denkt, das ist ein Quartett, was mache ich als fünfter Mensch eh schon hier, fühlt sich schon ausgeschlossen. Irgendwer hat ihm gesagt, komm doch einfach vorbei, okay, das ist meine einzige Chance. Kommt rein, alle schreien, werfen das Metronom auf den Boden und beschliessen dann, das ganze Vorhaben aufzulösen. Was ist aus ihm denn dann geworden? Das ist das traumatische Erlebnis aller Zeiten. Ja gut, aber er hat halt eine Story. Er kann immer sagen, wie mir haben sich die Rolling Stones aufgelöst. Er kann immer sagen, wegen... Nee, er hat eben keine Story. Wegen ihm haben sich eine Band aufgelöst, die nicht mein Thing war. Zu früh aufgelöst, ja. Habt ihr einen anderen Song auch nochmal gesungen oder nur den Gaia-Chor? Nur Gaia-Chor. Oh mein Gott, das ist gar keine Story. Vor allem in dem Gaia-Chor geht es halt auch um Freundschaft. Für alle Zeit. Wir sind Freunde für alle Zeit. Ah, okay, wir hören ja auf, das lassen wir. Wir brechen es hier ab. Ja, lassen wir auch getrennte Wege gehen. Es ist ein toller Song, aber ich werde ihn immer ein bisschen melancholisch singen ab jetzt, weil ich damals, also anders als er klingt. Ja, das stimmt. Wahnsinnig euphorisch und happy. Das sind Geier, ne? Das sind Geier, vier Stück. Die essen Ars. Deswegen hatte ich nie Angst um Mowgli in dem Moment. Das stimmt, weil die erst essen, wenn er sterben würde. Die würden ihn erst essen, wenn er sterben würde, und dann habe ich als Kind gedacht, dann ist ja auch egal. Dann ist er auch stückweit egal. Also du hast gar nie an Begräbnisrieten oder sowas gedacht, also das war dir gar nicht wichtig als Kind. So wirklich Totenruhe hat dich, also der Stefan, der interessiert sich für Fussball, Musik, aber was ihn weniger interessiert ist Totenruhe. Totenruhe. Okay, so bei der Einschulung. Ja okay, im Sinne von er schändet Gräber oder im Sinne von, es spielt keine grosse Rolle in den Sinn. Nein, es ist ihm einfach nur egal. Also, er würde es nicht aktiv tun, aber er würde es dulden, wenn es andere tun. Warum erwähnen Sie das? Weil es ja eigentlich, ich glaube, den meisten Kindern ist das Konzept der Totenruhe eher egal. Sie haben ja gesagt, also was mag er gerne, was mag er nicht so gerne. Okay, das ist was anderes. Er interessiert sich für Totenruhe, aber es interessiert ihn nicht. Genau, sie haben ja auf ihrem Zettelstand Interessen und Desinteressen. Ich weiß, wir müssen den überarbeiten. Interessen sind Fußball, Musik und Gitarre und Desinteressen ist die Totenruhe. Ja, das war ihm wichtig, dass das nochmal explizit geschrieben wurde. Und Redundanzen. Das stimmt, ja. Okay. Und Desinteressen, Totenruhe. Und sonst noch Desinteressen? Nein, alles andere. Totenruhe ist Desinteressen. Das ist das einzige, wo er eher desinteressiert ist. Alles andere, da kann man ihn mitkriegen. Aber haben Sie den Zettel mit ihm ausgefüllt und er hat nicht gewusst, was er schreiben soll, oder kam das sofort aus ihm raus? Nee, das war sofort da. Das war das Erste, was er gesagt hat. Das war sofort da, da wusste er sofort bei Gitarre mussten wir ein bisschen kämpfen. Gitarre hat ein bisschen gedauert. Will er nicht hin, ne? Aber Totenruhe, das kam sofort. Das kam sofort aus der Pistole geschossen. Sofort war es da. Aber er hat das Konzept Desinteresse verschoben. Es klingt ein bisschen so, als wäre der ein Überfokus auf Menschen, was mit Menschen passiert, wenn sie tot sind. Ist aus der Familie jemand gestorben oder so?
Ja, tatsächlich ist Tante Erna letztens gestorben,
da war er nicht bei der Beerdigung dabei.
Weil er gesagt hat, das interessiert mich nicht so sehr.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, das ist auch in Ordnung.
Also wenn das für dich nicht so deine Welt ist, dann ist das auch okay.
Okay, okay.
Also schauen Sie, dass da vielleicht jetzt im Unterricht
nicht primärer Fokus auf Begräbnis oder ... Nee, hatten wir nicht vor. Okay, na gut, dann ist ja wunderbar, dann ist das ja die richtige Schule für uns. Ja, ich glaube, wir erscheinen uns gegen, Stefan. Wie meinen Sie? Ich finde es weird, ich finde ihn weird. Aber muss sich denn jeder für Totenruhe interessieren bei Ihnen? Was ist das denn für ein Regime der Toten? Die Lebenden sollen leben. Haben die Toten hier das Sagen oder was? Und nicht die Lebenden. Ich glaube, von Ihnen kommt auch was, dass er so als wie er ist. Das ist ja jetzt Unterstellung, also das ist ja wirklich, das ist ja Unsinn. Ich sage nicht, dass die Toten regieren, ich sage nur, dass jemand, der sofort bei Desinteresse aus sich heraus schreit, Totenruhe, eher ein komisches Kind ist. Frau Brugmühl, wir sind noch lange genug tot. Wir sollen doch diese Momente, diese Essenz des Lebens genießen, solange wir sie noch haben. Im Sinne von Yolo? Im Sinne von kulturellem Prozess Yolo? Im Sinne von Musik, Gitarre und Fussball. Jetzt in dem konkreten Fall. Gitarre ist Musik. Ja, aber noch, Ja, das stimmt schon, aber ...
Da muss ich Sie fragen, interessieren Sie sich vor Totenruhe.
Es klingt so, als ob Sie in Ihrem Kind ausleben, was Sie selber ...
Ich wollte früher Bestatter werden, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe die falschrum eingegraben, Bauch nach unten.
Jetzt drehe ich mich um zu den anderen Kindern und sage, keine weiteren Fragen.
Denn alle Kinder des Kindergartens waren anwesend während des Vorstellungsgesprächs über das neue Kind. Die Kinder entscheiden, welches Kind sie neu haben wollen in der Schule. Ah, das ist so ein moderner, progressiver, demokratischer... Oder ein sehr, sehr alter, längst vergessen, überholteres Konzept. Es kommt ja immer wieder, ne? Es kommt ja alles immer wieder. Alles kommt immer wieder, selbst die schlechten Sachen. Aber weil du es gesagt hast, es ist redundant, erinnere ich mich immer noch gerne an einen, früher in der Schule, ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, aber ich liebe es, und da ist man ja in der Schule, ich liess es einfach, und in der Schule ist man ja manchmal, hat man seinen eigenen Klassenraum, aber manchmal ist man auch in anderen Klassenräumen, für besondere Anlässe und das ist was Besonderes. Wir hatten tatsächlich nie einen eigenenes... Ihr wart immer normal. Na, beim Sprechen ist mir aufgefallen. Nee, wir hatten schon immer andere... Ja doch, wir hatten eigentlich immer andere... Okay, dann ist ja in Ordnung. Also auf jeden Fall ist man manchmal woanders und dann ist auch der Klassenraum anders dekoriert worden von den anderen Kindern und dann standen da so Steckbriefe, was ich mag, was ich nicht mag. Und dann war da so der eine Steckbrief irgendwie von Jutta, die geschrieben hat, was ich mag, Pferde, Geschichten, Sport, Schwimmen, was ich nicht mag, Spinat, Jungs, Hitler. Und da habe ich auch gedacht, naja, technisch gesehen hast du ja schon Jungs geschrieben, also du musst Hitler gar nicht nochmal erwähnen, der ist eigentlich schon damit durch. Es sei denn, die Schrecken Hitlers sind geschlechterübergreifend, dass sie ihn auf eine Art Sockel heben. Du meinst, auch eine Frau hätte Hitler sein können, Frau Hitler hätte es auch geben können. Das ist nicht, was ich sage.
Ich kann einen Anwalt anrufen. Du meinst, auch eine Frau hätte Hitler sein können. Frau Hitler hätte es auch geben können. Das ist nicht, was ich sage.
Ich kann einen Anwalt anrufen für diese... Ja, gerne. Kein Problem. Es gibt diverse Podcast-Anwälte, die einfach... Sie sind gerade dabei, sich in Kopf und Kragen zu reden. Rufen Sie uns an, Dr. Kopf und Hermann Kragen.
Hier sind Dr. Will und Dr. Tietze. Wir beide helfen Ihnen. Tietze, genau so, Will und Partner.
Ja. Warum und ein Partner, dass es nicht so klingt, als wäre es mehrere Partner. Will und ein Partner. Will und ein Freund. Will und ein Freund. Ich finde es gut, dass der Name, wie er geschrieben ist, auch was die Größe der Namen und so angeht, schon aussagt, dass es Streit gab bei der Namensfindung. Weil irgendwie ist dann Will und ein Partner und die einste und so nachträglich offensichtlich dazugekommen auf dem Gebäude und Partner ist gross, grösser als Will. Also das ist so eine, wo man die Verhandlungen mitmerkt. Weil ja Will ist ja kürzer, deswegen können wir es ja grösser schreiben, damit es ein Gleisungsvielfalt ist. Ja, aber Name ist gar nicht vorhanden, ich heisse nicht Partner. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das weißt. Ja, aber du bist doch Partner. Ja, aber du bist ja auch mein Partner. Dein Name kommt trotzdem drauf. Ein Partner, nicht dein Partner. Du bist ein Partner, ich bin auch ein Partner. Ja, aber da will ich nur eins. Wenn du nur Partner schickst, will ich nur eins Partner. Will und eins Partner. Das ist doch Quatsch, das ist ja hier dritter Sprech jetzt. Das ist modern. Wir können nicht sagen Will und eins Partner. Ich will auch ein bisschen Jugendlicher rüberkommen. Warum willst du Jugendlicher rüberkommen? Jugendliche haben kein Geld, die haben keine juristischen Probleme. Wir wollen die alten Leute, die richtig tief drinstecken. Okay, dann Will und Ein, Römisch Eins Partner. Das klingt, als wärst du der erste Partner. Dann denkt man, wo ist der zweite? Ja, okay, ausgeschrieben ein. Aber da möchte ich, Partner soll grösser sein, grösser als will. Ja, okay. In Klammern Stefan. Oder wenn ihr uns einfach so Jura-Studio oder sowas. Oder halt irgendwie sowas Witziges. Ja, irgendwie eure YouTube-Anwälte oder sowas. Ja, genau. Ja, okay, perfekt. Und wir beraten euch, wenn ihr euch mit Kopf und Kragen redet, ruft uns einfach an. Aber mittendrin, das Problem bei Kopf und Kragen ist ja, man ruft oft erst den Anwalt aus, wenn es zu spät ist. Du musst währenddessen direkt, wie so ein Notfallknopf bei der Bank, so unterm Tisch brauchst du schon, während du merkst, dass man dann schon direkt. Und du hast Anwälte, die direkt, die auch gar kein, also völlig übermüdet sind, weil die immer am Start sein müssen. So Notfallanwälte, die du anrufen kannst, die sofort rangehen, wie so eine Notfallhotline. Ich liebe diesen Knopf unter dem Tisch, das finde ich eine der witzigsten Gesten überhaupt, so im Gespräch, so langsam die Hand unter dem Tisch und dann aber ganz, ganz deutlich drücken. Das Problem ist nämlich, ich finde die Positionierung ist nicht optimal, weil Hände und Arme liegen oft auf dem Tisch, Ellenbogen teilweise abgestützt.
Also man hat immer, es ist immer eine, während man versucht, Augenkontakt zu halten, immer eine lange Geste, unauffällig die Hand unter den Tisch zu bekommen, um dann diesen roten, grossen Buzzer zu drücken. Aber ist es nicht in modernen Banken eher so eine Fussmatte, so eine Tanzmatte, dass man sozusagen während man die Hände hoch hat und dann einfach mal so linker Fuss vorne, rechter Fuss hinten, zwei hin und her und dann kommt die Polizei. Ich dachte, das ist eher so was mit Füssen. Oder so mit der Hüfte, dass man so seitlich so einmal so nach rechts drückt. Kann man nicht sagen, Alexa ruft die Polizei. Nein, Alexa, nein! Das können Sie nicht machen. der Einbrecher dann immer, Alexa, lösche letzten Befehl. Das können wir den ganzen Tag machen. Und Alexa so, Leute, was soll ich machen? Ja, Alexa spielt einen Song. Rrrrruf die Polizei. Hier ist Ruf die Polizei von Falco. Es gibt auch für alles einen Song, glaube ich. Ja, klar gibt es für alles einen Song. Einen Song. Einen Song. Für alle Zeit. Warst du Bass, Mariton, Alt, Sopran, noch nicht fertig, Alt, Sopran oder Supersopran? Ich war definitiv nicht Supersopran, auf gar keinen Fall. Nee, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, ich war die tiefste Stimme, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr... Also Bass. Sehr, sehr, sehr... Nee, du sagst es nur laut, du singst es nicht. Sehr, sehr... So, es wird eher schlimmer, es wird eher schlechter. Aber das ist mir auch aufgefallen, als ich mit dir Gesangsunterricht hatte, dass du sehr, erstens noch traumatisiert ein bisschen bist, zweitens sehr mathematisch range gehst, also wenig Gefühl. Man muss sich Florentin vorstellen, aus dem weicht jegliche Körperlichkeit, Musikalität, er bleibt starr stehen, Augen weit aufgerissen, indem er versucht, das Wort zu Nail, eigentlich bestätig nachzumachen, wie es ihm vorgemacht wird, was dann dazu führt, vor allem bei dem Wort Jacke, dazu führt er, Jacke, Jacke,ke. Häng die Jacke. Ne, sag einfach doch Jacke. Häng die Jacke. Guck mal, du sagst doch normalerweise auch nicht Jacke. Häng die Jacke. Wo kommt denn jetzt das R? Das ist kein R, Buchstaben wie Jacke. Jacke, J-A-H-R-Z-K-E-R-Jacker. Das war sehr lustig. Aber okay, dann weiss ich nicht, woher es kommt. Es kommt aus deiner traumatischen Geier-Vergangenheit. Es ist wirklich traumatisch. Ich singe gerne, aber oft allein. Völlig okay. Ich finde auch ein Quartett mit fünf Leuten ist schon zum Scheitern verurteilt. Schwierig. Einer muss fliegen. Ist allen klar. Stellst du dir manchmal vor, dass du so gewisse Künstler so löschen kannst und dann selber so tun kannst, als hättest du deren Songs geschrieben? Du meinst dem Film Yesterday, wo die Beatles plötzlich nicht mehr existieren. Ich würde es genauso auch machen. Und dann würde kein Song einfallen. Weil angenommen, ich wäre in dieser Parallel, habe ich nämlich gedacht, Today is gonna be the day, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, zenn, z gibt keine Beatles, aber davor, weil das würde ja nicht, es würde ja eine Woche dauern, wie lange würde es dauern, bis einem auffällt, dass die Beatles nicht existieren? Das würde ja erstmal eine ganze Weile dauern. Genau, Florian hat nicht verstanden, dass man dem Film auch Zeitsprünge erzählen kann oder sowas. Das heisst, ja, die Version, die du geguckt hast, hat man erst viereinhalb Stunden.
Er geht zur Arbeit, ganz normal bei Obi so, da müssen sie gucken, also sie können natürlich jetzt die grosse Schraube nehmen oder zwei kleine. Das geht drei Stunden. Der Obi-Dialog dauert sehr lange. Er ist sehr lange bei Obi. Und man muss wirklich sagen, es ist mehr Dinge passieren, die nicht so erzählenswert sind. Ja, ich meine, ab wann würde man sagen, sag mal, ich habe lange schon nicht mehr Beatles gehört. Das würde einem nicht auffallen.
Vielleicht sind ja, vielleicht sind schon Bands verschwunden.
Es fällt einem, vielleicht geht unser Traum schon in Erfüllung.
Es fällt einem nur nicht auf, wenn man sich denkt, weil etwas, das fehlt, fällt nicht auf.
Sag mal, Robbie Williams habe ich auch schon jetzt locker seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr gehört.
Wo ist denn eigentlich Cher?
Und alle, wer?
Cher!
Ich kenne keinen Cher. Wie Cher?är? Wer? Schär. Wer? Schär. Wie der Stuhl? C-H-A-I-R? Nein, Schär. Schär, S-H-A-R-E, die teilen. Nein, Schär. Wie schreibt ihr das Schreiben, Schär? Können wir die Szene rausschneiden?
Irgendwie weiß ich.
Aber dann ist es ein Gitarrist und er weist noch diese ganzen Songs von den Beatles.
Und alle halten ihn dann für den Greatest Songwriter of all times, weil er halt noch alle Songs spielen kann.
Er geht zur Radiostation, spielt dann da Songs und alle sagen krass, wie schnell schnell du neue Songs erfinden kannst und wie toll du verschiedene Musikrichtungen kombinieren kannst und krass, wie versatil und cool du bist als Musiker, weil er halt alles von den Beatles über die Jahrzehnte gebraucht hat und mehrere Leute sind plötzlich einfach alles verkörpert als Gitarrist. Und da habe ich gedacht, ich würde es auch machen, natürlich, mir würde aber kein Song nur einfallen. Vor allem, ich glaube, es ist wirklich Horror, weil du würdest immer denken Mann, da war doch noch einer Black Road, Bird Road Cranberry Road Man kann es ja nicht googeln. Ah, fuck, Cranberry Hill nee, nee, warte, warte, warte, warte Strawberry Hills Storyfields nee, das war das ist ein wichtiger Funke Ich glaube, es ist wirklich einfach, ho. Ja, wir kommen gleich zurück aus der, wir gehen kurz in die Werbung, ich glaube. Ähm, nee, nee, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, w ein Hitradio-Unternehmen. Sorry, sorry, sorry, ich bin nah dran.
The Trojan Horse, where, where, nee, Yellow Horse.
Ich weiß nicht, wovon Sie reden, ich kenne die Band nicht, die Sie zitieren wollen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie können sich auch verraten.
Ach ja, Radio-Hit, ja.
Nee, dann machen wir kurz Werbung.
Wir machen kurz Werbung, vielen Dank, wir sind gleich zurück.
Ich hab's gleich.
Clark.
Ihr wisst das doch, oder? Macht's doch einfach. Radio Hit Welle! Radio Hit Welle 2!
Ne, ich glaube, es wäre wirklich der Horror. Man wünscht sich was, aber wenn es passiert, glaube ich, ist es der Horror. Man würde sich das wieder zurückwünschen, weil Robbie Williams kommt zurück. I just wanna feel real love and I hope that I gewin. Es ist ihr Song, ich verstehe nicht, warum sie diese Fragen stellen. I got too much life oder love? Ein bisschen an Ihrer Performance-Arbeit. Ich weiss, ich weiss. Das wirkt so zögern, das wirkt so skeptisch. Ich weiss. Ja, okay. Ich bin hier für einen Auftritt und nicht für ein Feedback-Gespräch, okay? Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber Sie singen halt nicht. Ja, ich weiss! Sie suchen nach Textzeilen. Ja! Ihrer eigenen Songs. Ja, weiss ich. Weißt du. Manche Leute sind auch nicht zum Rockstar gemacht. Die haben einfach die falsche Persönlichkeit, unabhängig vom musikalischen Talent. Ja, weiß ich. Ja, fucking nerviger Typ einfach. Aber der beste Musiker der Welt, er hat Cranberry Hills. Strawberry Fields. Strawberry Fields. Oh, Jesus Christ, ey. Aber würdest du lieber einen kompletten Künstler löschen und den ersetzen? Oder vier. Ich kann alle Songs von Cher, Beatles, Huey Lewis and the News und Schnappi, das kleine Krokodil. Oder würdest du eher eine Playlist machen? Würdest du eher so 20 Songs von verschiedenen Künstlern oder würdest du lieber so einen Künstler komplett mit seiner gesamten ... Es ist noch schwieriger herauszufinden, dass diese konkrete Playlist verschwunden ist. Aber vielleicht, das ist vielleicht auch ein Film, The Playlist. So, du machst eine Playlist oder genau so, das mysteriöse neue Mädchen in der Schule. Und Außenseiter niemand interessiert sich für sie. Und sie heißt Playlist. Langsam, kann ich erst so. Und sie kommt in die Schule und alle so. Und die Playlist-Paylist. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und sie, die zieht sich anders an, die ist nicht so girly wie alle anderen die populären Girls in der Klasse. Und unser Protagonist ist aber, sieht da durch sozusagen und freundet sich mit ihr an. Und alle sagen, er hat die Fähren von dir, die kommt aus einer gefährlichen Familie, du weißt doch, was mit ihrer Mutter passiert ist. Sie wohnt jenseits der Autobahn. Genau, sie wohnt südlich der Autobahn. Oh nein, da wohnen die Schlimmen. Und wir ein bisschen so eine Romeo und Julia Geschichte, so durch Widrigkeiten kommen sie zusammen und dann heißt es so, nein, ihre Mutter ist eine Hexe und so Quatsch, stimmt doch gar nicht, gibt's gar nicht und so. Und dann stellt er eine Playlist zusammen für sie, weil er sich in sie verliebt hat, Playlist und dann schickt er ihr die Playlist im Sinne von so, hey, jetzt über die Sommerferien, keine Ahnung, dachte ich...
Modernes Mixtape. Genau, ein modernes Mixtape, so, hey, über die Sommerferien, keine Ahnung, hier ist mein Sommermix, falls du Lust hast, stellt sich raus, sie ist doch auch eine Hexe. Ah, okay. Und sie verzaubert dann diese Playlist und löscht die sozusagen im Sinne von so, das ist nur unsere Playlist, niemand anders kennt die. Und dann stellt er fest, oh, niemand anders kennt die Songs. Und dann kann er wiederum die Songs neu aufnehmen und wird reich und berühmt. Und sie feiern gemeinsam eine erfolgreiche Karriere, weil sie dann doch eine Hexe war. Also erste Hälfte Stranger Things Hexen Supernatural Shit, zweite Hälfte Yesterday. Einfach eins zu eins. Guck mal, du kriegst zwei Filme für den Preis von einem. Es ist ein Double Feature. Das ist doch genial, du kriegst doppelt so viel Film in einem Film.
Geil.
Das ist so wie wenn Herr der Ringe zwischendurch einfach Speed wird.
Und das ist alles auch Matrix.
Also man sieht so ganz kurz, dass die alle in so Glaskanistern liegen, in so Gelee und man denkt sich, ah geil, Matrix auch noch.
Das ist wie Herr der Ringe und in der Mitte steigt dann Gandalf auf Schattenfell und reitet los, aber er darf nicht unter 50 kmh landen, sonst explodiert der Bus. Und er muss immer so im Kreis reiten. Hey Leute, wollen wir nur sagen, dass es ein Problem gibt? Und das ist der Film. Das ist nicht eine Szene, sondern dass da bleiben wird. So ist der Pitch gerade von dir. Ja, finde ich schlecht, warum nicht, dass du einfach nicht damit rechnest, dass es jetzt Speed ist plötzlich. Was war los bei Speed? Der Bus darf nicht langsam fahren. Nicht unter 50 oder so. Also da hat irgendjemand eine Bombe platziert und gesagt, du, pass mal auf, wollen wir die Bombe nicht an Tacho anschließen? An Tachometer meinst du? Ja, ich sag sag kurz Tacho. Wir sind Terroristen, wir haben viel Zeit zu verlieren. Du bist noch bei Tachometer? Nein, nein, nein, mein Freund. Aber guck mal, ich hab auch ein Thermo dabei. Dann können wir gucken, ob der Sprengstoff zu warm ist. Ein Thermo am Tacho? Ein Thermo am Tacho, kein Problem. Er ist ein sehr mathematischer Terrorist, der offensichtlich
genau wollte,
dass der Bus ... Was war die
Botschaft des Terroristen?
War das eine politische Botschaft? Unsere Welt ist so schnelllebig
und so. Oder war das so eine für 30er-Zonen
...
War das so ein Ruheabteil-Terrorist, der gesagt hat,
immer wenn Dezibel höher sind,
dann explodiert der Zug.
Florentin, das wäre ja
perfekt. Ich habe eine Bombe
hier im Abteil appliziert.
Wenn es lauter als
zehn Dezibel
wird, wird der gesamte Zug
in die Luft sprengen. Ist das der Florentin-Will von
Rocket Beans? Das waren jetzt acht Dezibel.
Wenn es über zehn Dezibel ist, dann fliegt ja alles in die Luft.
Das ist ja hilarious. Alle schreien leise.
Boah, das ist aber, fände ich jetzt schon anstrengend, im Kino zu gucken, diesen Film.
Richtig anstrengend, ja. Weil das die ganze Zeit leise ist.
Ja, ja. Und wenn du noch so ein Noise-Canceling anhast und es so wegklippt.
Der Soundtrack ist ganz leise. Und im Kino hört man alles. Und alle so rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr. Weil ich will dich jetzt nicht aufrufen zu einem terroristischen Anschlag, gar nicht. Aber ich möchte sagen. Der Anwalt ist nur einen Kn bisschen zu soft, finde ich, hast du gemacht. Du hast nämlich nichts gemacht, dass irgendwie deine Petition da so ein bisschen, nicht mal eine Stickerkampagne, nicht mal ein Manifest. Ja! Oh Gott, ey, Sassy, weirdo. Deswegen möchte ich einfach, dass du diesen Terroranschlag machst. Okay. Ich glaube, das würde dich wirklich und das ganze Vorhab das ganze Vorhaben weiterbringen. Mach wie Speed mit Sandra Bullock, ist nämlich jetzt Quiet Please, das ist der zweite Teil von Speed. Nach Quiet Please kommt Quiet Please oder was? Quiet Please, Decibel, Decibel, Speed. Ja, finde ich gut. Kein Mucks. Noisiness. Dezibomb. Mhm. Dezibomb. Ja, beim Namen kommen wir nochmal drauf zurück. Wir geben das mal in die MF. Marktforschung. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da SMF abkürzt. Mefo. SMF? Supermarktforschung? Ja, wenn, dann nehmen wir die. Okay. Aber es ist nur ein Gefühl. Und dann gibt es halt eine Bombe und die geht hoch, wenn der Ruheabteil zu laut ist. Oh, das wäre ein Traum für mich. Ich meine, du kannst ja auch einfach sagen, dass es eine Bombe gibt, ohne dass es eine gibt. Das ist ja der alte Pistole unterm T-Shirt. Ist auch verboten, diese Drohung. Ich finde das so lustig. Es gibt so ein soziologisches Experiment, wo Leute in ganz leisen Raum eingesperrt werden, wo kein Geräusch zu hören ist, nichts hängt, nichts ist, einfach nur pure Langeweile dieser Raum. Da hängt nichts an den Wänden, es ist einfach nur ein weisser Raum, und wenn man Menschen da reinsetzt, langweilen die sich halt obesslich zu Tode. Und dann gibt es dieses Experiment, wo sie in diesem Raum noch einen Knopf machen. Und die sagen denen vorher, wenn sie den Knopf drücken, kriegen sie einen ganz dollen Stromschlag. Er bringt sie nicht um, aber er tut sehr weh. Und Menschen, die sich so sehr langweilen, weil sie in diesem Raum sind, drücken alle im Schnitt dreimal oder so diesen Knopf, um sich selbst zu verletzen. und ich finde, das sagt so viel über uns Menschen aus. Und ich behaupte auch, ich meine, das war auch irgendwie die, man muss nur mal genau reinlesen, reich nach, oder könnt ihr bei Reddit nachlesen, wie es jemand anderes nachreicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist mehr geworden in den letzten Jahren, weil wir halt auch auf gewisse Weise uns immer mehr Dinge aussetzen und gewohnt sind, Reiz zu bekommen immer wieder. Moment, man macht dieses unglaublich brutale Experiment einfach einmal im Jahr oder was und guckt dann, wie es sich verändert. Ich will ehrlich gesagt dahin. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt irgendwie so aus den frühen 70ern, heute sind solche Folter-Experimente verboten, aber du so, nee, das ist in den letzten zwei Wochen ist das wieder um 30 Prozent gestiegen. Als würde man jeden Tag dieses Experiment machen. Finde ich auch gut, dass man eine Studie macht über die Häufigkeit dieses Experiments und wie die das zugenommen hat in den letzten drei Jahren. Aber ich hätte Bock drauf. Es ist so, ich stelle mir vor, dass ich dann so während des Experiments merke, dass ich Teil des Experiments bin und dann aber auch weiss schon, worum es geht. Und dann drücke ich mehrmals drauf, noch mehr, um die Stadt Studie zu verändern. Sei mir nicht böse, aber ich glaube, die meisten Menschen realisieren, dass sie Teil eines Experiments sind, wenn sie in einem weissen Raum mit einem roten Knopf sind. Die wenigsten denken, ach, ich verhalte mich jetzt hier ganz natürlich. Jeder Mensch, der da drin sitzt, denkt, ah, ich bin hier Teil eines Experiments. Da bist du nicht so viel weiter. Ich bin so yes and, dass ich häufig in solchen Situationen bin, wo ich nicht genau weiß, wie bin ich hier gerade gelandet, was ist das für ein Raum? Ich denke mir dann nicht sofort, ah, ich bin in einem Raum. Aber du hast doch davor eine Einverständniserklärung unterschrieben. Das war eine Red Flag. Das muss ich sagen. Das hätte mir zu denken geben können. Okay, aber du dachtest, ach ja, interessanter ist Restaurant. Ich bin jetzt Mitglied bei Greenpeace oder so was. Ja, klar. Oder genau, irgendwie so ein experimentales Molekularküchen-Restaurant oder sowas. Schmerz-Restaurant. Unterschiedliche Arten von Schmerz, die man sich so geben kann. Aber ist das ein Produkt, das einfach so in der Hand, so du drückst drauf und es tut weh? Was meinst du jetzt? Darf man das verkaufen? Na klar. So Stromschock? Ich hab ganz doll Magenknurren. Ja? Ich muss dringend angewöhnen, vor Aufnahmen was zu essen. Och nein. Ganz vergessen. Willst du was zu essen? Ich hab ein Brezel dabei. Das ist so unangenehm beim Hören.
Das war auch mal so ein ... Wenn's dir nicht gut geht, musst du es sagen, ne, dann machen wir eine Pause, kannst du dich kurz hinlegen.
Nee, ich möchte den Hörern sagen, das ist Geräusch, was ihr die ganze Menge gerutscht hat, tatsächlich Bauchknurren ist.
Das geht schon.
So wie wir immer ansprechen, dass draußen gerade zum Beispiel die Kirchenglocken angehen, immer ein Riesen-Bit draus machen und merken auf den Aufnahmen, dass es niemand hört. Ja, ich habe da letztes Mal reingehört und wir hören hier Kirchenglocken und machen ein Riesending draus. Oh Gott, oh Domini Sanktosati! Gott bestraft uns für unsere Witze, oh nein, oh nein! Und auf der Aufnahme hört man gar nichts. Und es muss ein absoluter Was-Moment gewesen sein für unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, weil...
Kurze Rückversicherung, denkt ihr, wir sind besch... also wir sind verrückt?
Ja genau, sag das mal ganz kurz.
Könnt ihr kurz mit Handzeichen sagen, ob wir verrückt sind?
Das denke ich mir so, weil viele Leute, die bescheuert sind, wissen ja nicht, dass sie bescheuert sind.
Das heißt, ich würde auch gerne mal irgendwie zum Arzt gehen und fragen, und fragen, bin ich bescheuert, also bin ich ... oder nicht? Also ... Ich finde, manchmal liegt's auch an der anderen Person, ob man bescheuert wirkt oder nicht. Ich hatte aber eine Situation, da war ich bei einem Auftritt, es war vor ein paar Jahren, von John Cleese hier in Köln. Der hat hier seine Show gespielt Show gespielt. Monty Python, ja. Monty Python, genau.
Und ich war dann da
und hab jemanden getroffen, den ich nicht so gut
kenne, eine Autoritätsperson.
Kann aber den Namen nicht sagen.
Wo ich gearbeitet hab.
Bundeskanzlerin? Genau.
Eine Autoritätsperson.
Also ich denke jetzt erstmal an Monarchen,
Premierminister, Minister im Allgemeinen. Ne Monarch im kleinen Sinne. Im Business-Sinne. In einem geschäftlichen Sinne, im Monarch. Na ja, ist ja auch egal. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe mich mit dieser Verfremdung des Namens abgelenkt von der Story ein bisschen. Was ich aber sagen möchte, genau, dann war ich da und ich habe, wollte dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Conversation machen und wollte dann so sagen, irgendwas Spannendes erzählen und mein Kumpel war an dem gleichen Auftritt von John Cleese den Tag davor in Hamburg. Was ich sagen wollte war, mein Kumpel war übrigens gestern in Hamburg, gedacht, bei John Cleese. Jetzt hat mich aber diese Autoritätsperson unterbrochen bei dem Satz, mein Kumpel war gestern in Hamburg.
Er hat gesagt, ah ja, cool, Story. Und dann stand ich da mit diesem Satz. Mein Kumpel war gestern in Hamburg und nur durch Social Awkwardness seitens der Autoritätsperson, der das nicht, der nicht wollte, was ist der Punkt, er hat es einfach so stehen lassen, als wäre der Satz, den ich sagen will und die Informationen, die ich rüberbringen will, mein Kumpel war gestern in Hamburg. Was mich und vor allem der ganzen Gruppe hat, blossgestellt hat, was war so gemein, weil er hält einen ja für bescheuert. Ja, was für ein absoluter Power-Move. Jede Geschichte ist im ersten Satz uninteressant. Sag mal, ich war letztens bei McDonalds. Wow, coole Geschichte. Okay, cool. War ich auch noch nie. Geil, Insider-Tipp. Gott im Himmel, ey. Das ist ja wirklich der unsympathischste Move. Nach dem ersten Satz. Das war so ein so ein scheiss Kackmove. Ach, geil. Ich bin letzte Woche im IC gefahren. Wow, super Geschichte. Mega geile Geschichte. Wow. Hast du noch mehr auf Lager? Warst du im McDonalds? Es ist so unangenehm. Und ich war The Laughing Song. Ich war so ein Idiot. Und es wirkte dann auch so, vom ganzen Timing, wie es abgelaufen ist, wirkte es so, als ob ich das sagen will. Also die einzige Information, die ich sagen will, mein Kumpel war gestern in Hamburg.
Wahnsinn.
Wahnsinn. Das war so ein, also... Wie kommt man da wieder zurück?
Ich habe mich den ganzen Abend nicht erholt. Ich habe auch mich nicht, ich erinnere mich an nichts, was John Cleese gesagt hat, weil ich mich die ganze Zeit daran aufgehangen habe, dass das passiert ist.
Er war aber auch schon bei John Cleese. Den ganzen Abend redest du nur mit dir, ich meinte ja nicht nur ein Hammer. Also er war auch bei der gleichen Show, das war schon erzählenswert. Pst, Stefan, pst, nein, nee, okay. Ich meine nur, es war schon erzählenswert, bei der gleichen Show, und ich wollte sagen, es war gut. Ich wollte doch nur sagen, das ist eine gute Show, aber wir uns aber das freuen. Jo, stehst du so auf und schleifst dich zu deiner Person. Ich wollte nur sagen, der mein anderer Freund, der war eine Homogon. Ja, genau. Ab der Seite, mega geile Story. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein! Fuck! Schon zum zweiten Mal. Vielleicht sollte ich anfangen mit dem Satz, die Show soll übrigens sehr gut sein, weil... So, jetzt aber, ihr hört doch was. Dominus Padro, Sanctus Domini! Das ist doch nicht zu überhören. Naja, aber die Technik ist so weit mittlerweile. Wie, dass die Glocken läuten oder göttliche Zeichen rausfiltern? Ja, das ist ein komplett atheistisches Mikrofon, das filtert alles Mögliche raus. Aber manchmal braucht man auch in der Gruppe einfach jemanden, über den es sich alle lustig machen. Aber ich will das nicht sein. Ich weiß, aber du bist halt so, es gibt ja auch diese Geschichte vom Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo Churchill und Roosevelt, also der britische Premierminister und der amerikanische Präsident, die wollten Stalin überzeugen. Zwei Autoritätspersonen. Zwei Autoritätspersonen. Die wollten zu Stalin, der dritten Autoritätsperson, und dann wollten die so den halt überzeugen, dass er auch, dass sie im Krieg zusammenarbeiten.
Und Churchill war so, okay, wie machen wir das jetzt, was legen wir dem vor, wie machen wir das strategisch, wie sollen wir strategisch im Gespräch das machen, das ist ein wichtiges Gespräch, und Roosevelt war so, ja, ja, ja, machen wir schon, kein Problem, wir reden erstmal mit dem Trinken und dann war das großes Essen, Stalin, Roosevelt und Churchill, und das erste, was Roosevelt... Was gibt's da zu essen? Wer muss, welche arme Sau, welche arme Sau
muss da in Rewe, woher?
Muss da schön so diese
Plastiksalate kaufen, dann
Vorkosten, damit die nicht vergiftet sind.
Und dann auch, welche Teller nehme ich?
Diese ganzen Entscheidungen, die getroffen werden.
Ist ja auf irgendeinem Schiff oder so wahrscheinlich,
wir haben jetzt nur diese Teller mit den
Uhren. Ja, die Servierten fehlen. Montgomery, die Servierten fehlen. Und dann sitzen die da und das Erste, was Roosevelt sagt, ist, guck dir mal an, wie fett Churchill ist. Und Stalin so, er ist so, what? Fängt dann aber an zu lachen. Mega Stimmung, Roosevelt und Stalin trinken zusammen, singen zusammen, haben einen geilen Tag und am Ende meint er so, ja seid ihr dabei im Krieg und Stalin so, ja ja ja, kein Problem. Und abends im Bett Churchill. Naja, ich stehe nun mal auch unter grossem Stress, ja, man wird bombardiert seit Jahren und so. Schatz, es ist super spät, ich war schon am Schlafen. Ich meine einfach nur, dass es auch ein bisschen genetisch in der Familie ist. Immer noch wegen dieser Meeting-Sache. Das war vor drei Jahren. Ich mach doch jetzt mal einen Augenblick. Naja, es ist irgendwie... Aber weißt du, du warst Churchill in dem Moment, der strategisch unter den Bus geworfen. Du musst manchmal auch einfach Leute unter den Bus werfen und sagen, guck dir an, wie fett dem Rahmen der ist um die Zukunft der Welt
literally gegangen, wäre ich glaube ich
entspannter gewesen. Es ging wirklich
nur um Sozialstatus.
Und diesen Dritten Weltkrieg
im kleinen Rahmen,
Zweiten Weltkrieg im kleinen Rahmen, habe ich einfach verloren.
Weißt du? Ja, okay, gut.
Kann man so auch sehen, wenn man will.
Die historische Tragweite dieses Treffens
war. Also genau, war schon entscheidend, dass man dann gerne, ja okay, wenn ich als Fett beschimpft würde, vor einer Gruppe, um dann den Zweiten Weltkrieg zu verhindern, zu eskalierend verhindern, I don't know. Crazy, aber was eine krasse Story. Ja. One for the team, Churchill. Aber was für ein Arschloch-Move auch. Ja, gut. Sozusagen, ja, wir. Sozusagen, wir haben das schon, ich habe das schon. Aber nicht sagen, dass man sich schon eine Idee hat, schon vorbereitet ist. Er hätte auch stief gehen können übrigens. Ja, klar.
Ja. Stadien sieht genauso aus wie Churchill.
Genauso die gleiche Körperform.
Und er meinte, er hier mit seiner Zigarre, guck dir den Trottel an, und Stadien auch so, wieso?
Hm?
Was?
Warum? Warum? Ach so. Warum, habe ich gefragt.
Naja, es sieht da so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Schornstein. Und dann Griemer schlangen zunehmend eben. Ich glaube, er wollte sie beleidigen, Sir. Er wollte sie wohl beleidigen. Hören Sie. Ja, okay, Wahnsinn. Also das sind Geschichtsfacts mit Florentin Will. Auf jeden Fall. Ich kann dir immer was reinstreuen, wenn es sein muss. Ich wollte dir nur historisch eine Perspektive bieten. Finde ich total geil, dass du mir auch für meine kleinen typischen Storys... Weil Churchill ist ja grosse Held. Wenn du heute nach England gehst, sagen alle Churchill Superheld. Der fette Held. So. Der grosse fette Held. Wird vielleicht auch eines Tages für dich eine Statue gebaut. Weißt du, das ist auch so ein Ding, ne? Bist du ein Jahr lang fett und genau da baut man die Statue. Ich denke mir das auch bei so Ritterrüstungen. Dann sieht man dann auch im Museum so eine Ritterrüstung von jemandem, der halt einfach korpululenter war und denkt so, der kann halt jetzt auch nicht mehr abnehmen. Ja, und der war auch nicht sein Leben lang wahrscheinlich so. Wie es unvorteilhafte Fotos gibt, gibt es ja auch unvorteilhafte Statuen. Ja, genau. Die wirken nur wirklich wie in Stein gemeißelt. Einfach ein dummer Wink, also könnt ihr euch vielleicht nicht, kommt da mal hier her. David so nach der Statue will er könnte mich, er könnte den Raum abschieben, dass man mich nur von links sieht, weil links ist irgendwie meine schöne Seite. David, das ist doch die perfekte Körperform, Michelangelo hat sie verewigt in Marmor. Ich, ja, erstmal, vielen Dank, erstmal ist auch sehr cool. Gerne, hab ich gerne gemacht, David. Danke, Michelangelo, Michael, wie ich sage, aber ich weiß nicht, also von dieser einen Seite gefällt es mir halt einfach besser so, weil ich gefällt mir selber von der einen Seite besser als von der Armand. Das verstehe ich, das verstehe ich. Aber natürlich für uns von außen hat natürlich auch so diese Asymmetrie was ganz Besonderes. Und diese gewissen kleinen Pfunde, die sind natürlich auch ganz süss. Ja, weil die habe ich ja im Jahr vielleicht nicht mehr. Ich würde mal laufen gehen, jetzt irgendwie,
dieses Fitbit-Armband und so geschenkt bekommen.
Ja, ist ja super.
Da können wir einfach nächstes Jahr noch eine Statue machen.
Und nach dem Kampf mit, ja, aber nach dem Kampf mit Goliath
denke ich mir auch so, werde ich bestimmt,
ist das der gleiche, da werde ich bestimmt
irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr Muskelkraft haben, so rapped sein,
weißt du, rapped. Und diese Statue,
ich habe nur das Gefühl, die wird halt ewig bestehen, so weit über meinen Tod hinaus.
Du, sag mal so, was wegklopfen kann man immer noch.
Das habe ich gehofft.
Das ist einfach, weißt du, guck mal, nur ganz kurz, eine Statue, wie funktioniert das?
Du klopfst alles weg, was du nicht brauchst, du kannst aber nichts hinzufügen.
Nee.
Das heißt, ich kann immer noch was wegklopfen, das geht immer, die Option hast du immer noch.
Kannst du mir, genau, Brustmuskulatur, die würde ich ja zulegen, Die Kaffee sind die Kaffee, die die Kaffee der Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die die Kaffee, die, das geht immer, die Option hast du immer noch. Kannst du mir,
genau, Brustmuskulatur,
die würde ich ja zulegen,
die kannst du nicht mehr dran machen.
Ich mag's, also ich mag's mega, aber das geht
jetzt nicht, ne?
Aber wenn du mich proportional
kleiner machst wieder, überall ein bisschen
was wegnimmst,
und da da was lässt, ich denke, du bist zum Brainstorming. Dann schwebst du aber in der Luft. Weil du kannst ja nicht... Oh, jeder nicht. Okay, Mensch David. Können wir diese Samtkordel vielleicht so stellen, dass man ihn von rechts nicht sehen kann? Du kannst ja mit der Samtkordel am Ende immer noch was machen. Klar, Michel Samtkordel. Weil klar, Michelangelo und so hat das Ding gemacht, aber wer die Macht über die Samtkordel hat, der hat ja quasi die gesamte Macht. Der hat das Zepter in der Hand. Der hat das Zepter komplett in der Hand. Michelangelo. Michelangelo, aber die Samtkordel, die setzt das ja nochmal in Kontext. Dass man manche Sachen gar nicht sehen kann, weil man da gar nicht hin kann, weil da ja die Samtkordel ist. Die Top 5 Statuenklopfer. Uff, spannend, das verändert sich auch ständig. Das ist nächste Woche wieder anders bei mir. Also das ist jetzt nur eine Momentaufnahme, das muss man dazu sagen. Der große Raphael bei mir auf Platz 5. Ja, klar. Auf 4 Rodin natürlich. Auf Platz drei bei mir Bernini. Uh, okay, dann würde ich direkt mal auf zwei Michelangelo mit reinwerfen. Ja, das wäre auch mein Platz zwei. Und dein Platz eins. Platz eins dann noch. Gerhard Richter. Der alte Statuenklopfer. Der baut die einfach so weg. Der kloppt die weg, ne? Da kommst du einmal nicht hin und dann kloppt der die weg. Das wäre unsere Kunstkritik dazu. Also der baut die, der macht die nicht einfach nur, der baut die dir weg. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das sagt, Statuenklopper, ob das die offizielle Bezeichnung ist. Ne, ist es nicht. Wir sagen das jetzt hier nur so.
Ich habe auch, ich muss letztens so ein neues Konto eröffnen und dann musste man so aus so einer ganz langen Liste für so Selbstständigkeit und dann musstest du so angeben, so was machen sie so.
Und dann gibt es anscheinend so einen riesigen Katalog von allen Berufen der Welt.
Und dann konnte man da so durchscrollen, das ist also eine lächerlich lange Liste von irgendwie Hochseefischer, Krabbentierbauer, halt wirklich die lächerlichsten Sachen. Marionettenspieler. Aber ich habe nichts gefunden, was zu mir passen würde. Aber hast du was gefunden, was metaphorisch zu dir passt? Also Marionettenspieler? In gewisser Weise. Ich habe mich dann für, ich glaube, irgendwie so Tiefdruck oder sowas entschieden. Tiefdrucktaucher. Also das sind Leute, die sind ganz in einem flachen Wasser. Weil die sind nicht Hochdrucktaucher ganz tief, sondern Tiefdruck ist eher so ein bis drei Meter tauche ich primär. Komplett entspannter Druck, Druckverhältnisse. Eigentlich nicht erwähnenswerte Druckverhältnisse. Das ist super verwirrend, weil der Hochdrucktaucher taucht tiefer, weil Wasser ist ja alles umgedreht. Die ganze Klasse, alle zusammen, der Hochseetaucher taucht tiefer, wo der Druck am grössten ist. Ich hatte eigentlich bei Desinteressen Hochseetaucher angegeben, es interessiert mich eigentlich gar nicht.
Grima, schreib auf.
Das machen wir nie wieder. Schreib auf, mit den Desinteressen machen wir nie wieder.
Ist notiert, mein Lord, selbstverständlich.
Ich will nicht mehr mit diesen Kindern über diese Desinteressen diskutieren müssen.
So, nochmal zurück zur Totenruhe. Also, Grima, töte Stefan. Ich glaube, ich habe am Ende, es gab, weil ich habe irgendwas mit Medien gesucht und am Ende gab es irgendwie so Mediendruck, irgendwie Drucktechnik oder so. Mir ist es mir jetzt auch egal. Im beides Sinne, ja. Das bin ich jetzt eben Drucker, von mir aus offiziell. Ich hoffe, es gibt nicht irgendeine Druckersteuer oder so, die jetzt irgendwie nochmal oben drauf berechnet wird. Aber es war einfach albern. Warum Print nicht stirbt? Dann, weil man bei solchen Listen nie findet, was man eigentlich mit Medien macht, sondern man findet Mediendruck. Und im weitesten Sinne ja. Ich erwarte jetzt auch, dass ich irgendwie so ein Pergamentschreiben bekomme von der Druckergilde, irgendwie da dieser ganz nach altem System Wieser Oldenburg, Gutenberg, nach gutenbergscher Drucktechnik da so einen Meisterbrief mir zuschicken, dass ich offiziell jetzt Teil der Druckergilde bin. Also, falls ihr irgendwas gedruckt wollt, technisch gesehen bin ich Teil der Druckergilde, ich wollte aber nur ein Sternchen an meinem Namen haben, eigentlich nicht. Also eigentlich habe ich keine Fähigkeiten. Ich stehe auf der Liste, aber nur aus Steuergründen. Du hast dich in so eine Sackgasse manövriert. Ich habe mich in eine Drucksituation hinein manövriert und das macht mich kaputt. Der Druck ist zu hoch. Der Druck ist zu hoch? Moment, Moment, jetzt geht's was? Der Druck ist zu hoch. Moment, also aber jetzt im Tiefdruck, nein, Hochdruckdrucker, das heisst, ich habe, ich bin Hochtiefdrucker, also das bedeutet, dass die ganzen von unten. Ich bin Tiefdruckdrucker, heisst, ich habe Spaß beim Drucken, weil der Druck, den ich selber beim Arbeiten verspüre, eher gering einzubewerten ist. Nichts zu häufigst mit den Hochdruckdruckern, die auf Hochdruck drucken. Aber was nicht heisst, dass sie unter hohem Druck drucken, sondern die sind einfach sehr schnell. Ja genau. Wohingegen Hochdruck-, Tiefdrucktaucher unter grosser Anstellung im seichten Gewässer schwimmen. Genau, und dann gibt es natürlich noch die Tiefsee-Hochdrucker, die unter Wasser drucken, falls eine Pipeline bedruckt werden muss. Ja, Wracks oder so müssen oft nochmal angedruckt werden. Das ist dann aber noch was ganz anderes. Oder die Hochdruck-Tiefseetaucher, die unter hohem Druck unter Wasser. Genau, vielleicht drucken, wissen wir nicht, arbeiten. Das ist sehr unklar, man nimmt mal erstmal eine Druckerpresse mit. Apropos Drucker, wo ich es gerade sage, wir sind ja auch wieder kurz davor, neue Dinge zu drucken, denn ja, es wird wieder neuen Merch geben endlich. Völlig richtig, und nachdem dieser Niemann-Drop und weil unser Grafiker Christoph Niemann, der unser UFO gemacht hat hat, so tolle Motive noch gemacht hat mit unserem Ufo, denn dafür ist es da, es soll verändert werden. Richtig. Es ist nur eine Outline. Es ist Leben in euren Händen. Es lebt, es ist ein Breathing Object, es lebt wie der Nike-Swoosh von eurem Input und deswegen haben wir jetzt an euch gedacht. Denn wer ist noch ein besserer Grafiker als Christoph Niemann? Du. Du. Vielleicht bist du's. Oder du. Oder du. Denn wir machen einen grossen Community-Drop. Wir haben, als wir dieses neue Logo bekommen haben, schon ganz viele neue Einsendungen von euch bekommt, wo ihr dieses Logo einbaut. Wir haben ganz toll Grafiken bekommen und davon wollen wir mehr, falls ihr Bock habt, auf unserem Merch zu erscheinen, denn wir wollen eure Kreativität nutzen und schauen, was ihr Tolles aus unserem Logo macht. Genau, dafür bekommt ihr natürlich dann Geld und wir brauchen eure Einsendungen. Und zwar könnt ihr uns bis zum 1. Juli eure Grafiken schicken und unter allen Leuten, die alle Voraussetzungen erfüllen und uns die richtige Datei geschickt haben, in der richtigen Grösse, ihr könnt euch ja besser aus als wir. Wie sie öffnen können, virenfrei. Wählen wir dann die Gewinner aus und sind ganz gespannt, was da von euch kommt. Und am Ende könnt ihr euer eigenes Bild auf eurem eigenen T-Shirt tragen. Alle Infos findet ihr auf unseren Social Media Kanälen und bis zum 1. Juli freuen wir uns auf eure Einsendungen. Meeresbiologe wollten viele werden bei uns in der Klasse, habe ich immer nicht verstanden. Ich glaube, Meeresbiologe ist so tatsächlich neben Feuerwehr und Polizei und so unter diesen ersten Basic-Ass-Berufen, die Kinder so haben, sehr weit oben im Rennen gewesen. Meeresbiologe. Ja, aber die wollen dann alle diesen Kraken finden oder was? Oder irgendwelche Tiere, die es noch nicht gibt. Oder waren die alle mal in der Türkei im Urlaub, waren zweimal tauchen und dachten, das ist jetzt mein Leben. Oder es kam vielleicht Ariel in dem Jahr raus und haben gesagt,
ich will Ariel finden. Untersuchen?
Ich will Ariel untersuchen.
Biologisch ist halt eher was
Forscherisches.
Das denkst du, als würden die Ariel
sezieren.
Ja, ist es nicht so, weil bei so Thunfisch-Fischern,
dass da Ariel manchmal so im Netz drin hängt,
dass die Mähungfrauen quasi mitgefischt werden und dann so als Abfälle dann zu Chicken Nuggets verarbeitet werden?
Soll man ja nicht essen Ariels? Es gibt ja dieses Ariel-Teacher, diese Doku. Ach so, du meinst, dass bei der Ariel-Jagd dann immer noch Seesterne mitgefangen werden. Es werden immer irgendein Bullshit noch mitgefangen. Weil die Thunfischfänger fangen Arielles mit und schmeissen die wieder rein und die Ariellfischer f fangen Ariels mit und schmeissen die wieder rein,
und die Ariellfischer fangen Thunfisch und schmeissen die wieder rein.
Können die nicht zusammenarbeiten?
Man sagt ja, Menschen schmecken nach Hühnchen.
Schmeckt Ariel eher nach Fisch oder Hühnchen?
Sehr gut, sehr, sehr gut.
Nur mal jetzt ...
Oder es ist geteilt nach Körperteil? Also der untere Teil nach Fisch? Sie kann ja auch unter Wasser atmen. Sie muss ja auch im oberen Teil was Fischiges haben. Kiem. Aber sind Kiem nicht das, was man wahrscheinlich isst beim Fisch.
Eher Filet.
Ich meine, trinken Fische auch Wasser? Also der Mensch muss ja ständig atmen, aber nur manchmal trinken. Fische müssen ständig trinken und nur manchmal atmen. Genau. Völlig richtig. Ich meine, die Satz jetzt, als wäre das das Ende des Satzes.
Naja, ich meine, es wäre auch eine Welt denkbar, in der der Mensch nur alle paar Stunden atmen muss, so wie trinken. Wo man halt sagt so, man muss nicht konstant atmen, sondern ich muss immer wieder atmen. Und dann ist man wieder für ein paar Stunden gut, so wie beim Trinken. Du atmest zu wenig. Genau, jeden Tag zwei Kubikmeter atmen. Leute, bitte, denkt dran. Und jetzt wie ist es bei Fischen? Fischen atmen ja auch ständig, aber halt Wasser. Vollständig bei so Marathonläufen, nicht so, dass man mit Trinkflaschen am Rand stehen, sondern mit so Atemgeräten oder sowas.
Ja, und dann muss man...
Geht man da hin und dann geht man weiter.
Und Fisch atmet ja wahrscheinlich auch ständig, aber halt Wasser.
Aber braucht ein Fisch auch Trink, also trinkt er ab, also einmal alle paar Stunden dann so einen runter. Und vor allem mit Salzwasser. Oder geht das automatisch auch mit dem Verarbeiten von Wasser. Es muss durch so ein Riesenfiltersystem gehen, weil du bist ja auch im Salzwasser. Du kannst ja nicht, also das wäre tödlich wahrscheinlich, wenn du die ganze Zeit Salz trinken würdest. Also kann ein Fisch verdursten, ist meine Frage. Also wenn er lange nicht, oder muss der aktiv noch was trinken, oder ist das der gleiche Kreislauf wie sein Atmen? Trocknen die denn aus an Land oder verdursten sie an Land? Sehr gut. Zuerst. Sehr gut. Keine Antwort. Du bist so weit. Sehr gut. Sehr gut, mein junger Paderwan. Okay. Mich finde ich richtig gut. Ja, es ist eine Frage, die jetzt einer Antwort bedarf. Hier eine Frage an die vielen Meeresbiologen an euch da draußen. Oh. Wollt ihr uns da helfen, hm? Da ist jemand sauer, der so nicht aufgenommen wurde. Oder habt ihr keinen Empfang auf eurem Kackboot mit einer kleinen Dreckskajüte, hm? Hm? Fährst du jetzt eigentlich in diesem Sommer wieder Boot? Ja, ich habe einen Gutschein geschenkt bekommen. Einen Tag darf ich Boot fahren. Jetzt ist es nur so, dass ich... Letztes Jahr haben wir das ganze Jahr damit verbracht, darüber zu reden, Stefan, Segelschein, Segelschein, Klapp das Jahr, Knoten, Zirkel, jetzt hast du deinen Segelschein, jetzt will ich dich aber auch auf dem Meer sehen. Ich habe vor zwei Jahren meinen Bootsführerschein gemacht, seitdem bin ich nicht mehr gefahren, habe alles vergessen, weil man halt das lernt, wie man für eine Schule lernt oder für einen Führerschein. Könnt ihr noch alle Schilder? Ich weiß nicht, was der rote Kreis mit der 30 drin ist, keine Ahnung, man weiß es nicht mehr, ist ja ganz normal. So, und jetzt habe ich genauso auch alles vergessen, was ein Bootsführerschein ist. Alle Knoten, ich wüsste keinen mehr, wirklich nicht. Und jetzt hat mir aber meine Familie einen Bootstag geschenkt, wo man sich so ein Boot mieten kann. Und am ganzen Tag kann man damit rumfahren. Und man kriegt das alleine, ja, mit Freunden, Familie, wo ever, dann dann drauf, nimmt was zu trinken mit. Das war auch die Erwartung der Person, die es geschenkt hat, oder? Nee, genau, und das ist der einzige Gutschein, dass je länger er jetzt nicht eingelöst wurde, die Leute, die es mir geschenkt haben, die eigentlich immer dazu drängen, jetzt löst du den Gutschein ein, löst du den Gutschein ein, mit der Zeit das Interesse verlieren, mit mir einen Tag auf dem Boot zu verbringen. Weil es immer unsicherer wird, weil deine Kompetenzen im Segeln weiter schwinden. Immer, verstehe ich ich, wo das Segeln herkommt. Das habe ich nämlich noch nie gemacht. Das werde ich sofort zu dem Unglück fahren. Es ist ein Motorboot. Und es ist wirklich der einzige Gutschein, wo man mir jetzt langsam nahelegt, den einfach verfallen zu lassen. Weil Leute haben wirklich Angst. Es wollen auch viele nicht mit mir fahren. Das ist eine sehr lustige Dynamik. Sag mal, du erinnerst dich noch, du hast mir doch vor drei Jahren diesen Flugzeuggutschein geschenkt, als ich die Flugzeugausbildung gemacht habe. Ich dachte mir jetzt, ich bin drei Jahre lang nicht geflogen. Wollen wir das jetzt doch nochmal machen? Das ist doch eine super Zeit jetzt. Doch, doch, vor drei Jahren, da warst du auf meinem Geburtstag und hast mir diesen Gutschein geschenkt. Das ist nicht von mir. Doch klar, natürlich, guck mal hier, das ist doch deine Unterschrift, oder nicht?
Ah, krass, ja.
Komm, lass uns das doch diesen Sommer machen, oder?
Aber der ist doch abgelaufen schon.
Nee, der hält fünf Jahre lang. Ich bin ein bisschen eingerostet jetzt, drei Jahre lang war ich nicht im Flugzeug und so,
aber ich glaube so grob dieses,
wie heisst es, Auftrieb und so, glaube ich, das kriege ich schon auch hin, oder?
Aber es ist so, dass ich nicht mehr, ich darf nicht mehr hoch. Ich habe ja diese Sache mit dem Hochdruck. Das ist doch perfekt. Nee. In der Luft ist es weniger Druck. Je höher du gehst, desto niedriger ist der Druck. Also es ist doch perfekt. Fuck! Nee, ich habe dieses, ähm, dieses. Das ist doch perfekt, dann musst du ja sogar hoch. Also das ist ja dann ideal eigentlich für deinen Zustand. Ja, ich darf nicht, ähm, oben sein. Ich darf nicht oben sein. Warum darfst du nicht oben sein? Ich muss eher runter. Warum hast du mir denn einen Gutschein geschenkt für ein Flugzeug ausgeliehen? Das ist neu, das ist ein neues Problem. Ach! Weil mein Arzt hat gesagt, ich will nicht mehr so gerne fliegen. Wirklich? Ich darf auch nicht mehr in den Gebirge oder so. Wieso das denn? Herz, mein Herz. Herz, schwaches Herz, zu stark, zu viel Blutdruck. Zu viel Blutdruck? Hochdruck, Bluttiefdruck. Ach, schade. Aber nimm doch Ja, wen soll ich mitnehmen, sag mal. Nimm doch Carina mit, die mögen wir alle so, die hat neue Freundin, die mögen wir alle so gerne. Ja, dann nehme ich Carina mit. Die mögen wir ja alle so, so, so gerne. Ja, wenn du sagst, ist ja nett von dir. Ich habe jetzt als erster nicht gedacht, weil du mir den Gutschein geschenkt hast, aber wenn du sagst Carina, dann ist doch in Ordnung. Nur Carina mit und wie wär's denn mit Bernhard? Carina und Bernhard nehme ich gerne mit. Genau, der ist jetzt auch von seiner Meeresausbildung zurück, also irgendwie genau. Und jetzt die Frage an die Klasse. Ist das Mord, wenn dieses Flugzeug abstürzt? Herr Tietze war sich der Inkompetenz des Piloten bewusst und hat aktiv dazu gedrängt, dass Carina im Flugzeug mitfliegt. Würde dieses Flugzeug jetzt abstürzen, könnte man eine Komplizenschaft oder einen Totschlag oder sogar Mord unterstellen. Ich würde sagen, die nicht unbedingt, denn die Entscheidung, selber zu fliegen, liegt ganz klar beim Beschenken. Der Gutschein sagt nur aus, hier, ein freier Tag. Aber wenn die Person im Wissen, dass es sich um eine Gefahrensituation handelt, eine Person aktiv in diese Situation hinein nötigt, darüber überredet. Die Überredung ist ja nicht der Fall, es ist ein Gutschein, ein Geschenk. Man kann es annehmen, man kann es verfallen lassen. Ich glaube, die Entscheidung, selbst zu fliegen, liegt hier allein beim Piloten. Er bringt sich in Gefahr und auch die Frage, ist es nicht immer ein Risiko, wenn ich ein Bungee-Jumping-Event verschenke, ist da auch ein gewisses Risiko drin. Menschen sterben, wenn sie, wie in Dortmund zum Beispiel vom Florianturm, ist mal einer gesprungen und dann ist er dann gegen den Turm geknallt. Wir machen eine Schweigeminute für diesen gefallenen Helden. Es tut mir leid, dass wir in letzter Zeit kaum noch dazukommen, weil wir ständig Schweigeminuten in unserem Mord- und Totschlag-Seminar machen.
Vielleicht zollen wir den Opfern zu viel Respekt, das muss man mir gefallen lassen.
Zu viel, wärst du für zu viel Respekt?
Am gewissen Punkt muss man auch wieder zurückrufen.
Die meisten sind für zu viel.
Offiziell wurde die Schweigeminute in Schweige 20 Sekunden geändert.
Der Bundestag gibt offiziell bekannt, die Schweigeminute wurde in die Schweige 20anzig Sekunden geändert. Der Bundestag gibt offiziell bekannt, die Schweigeminute wurde in die Schweige zwanzig bis dreissig Sekunden geändert, weil wir müssen ein bisschen Stoff durchkriegen voran. Es ist auch für uns letzte Stunde, wir müssen noch was durchballern. Es ist wirklich spannend, aber ich glaube, es ist kein Wort. Ich glaube, du musst selber die Entscheidung treffen. Es gibt nämlich Leute, die schon lange nicht mehr geflogen sind, dann wieder mal ein Flugzeug steigen
und es klappt nicht und so.
Ich meine, ich bin gespannt auf die Antwort der Juristen unter uns,
aber wenn du, angenommen, ich weiss, dass eine
Achterbahn kaputt ist.
Ich habe gesehen, dass da fehlt eine Schraube.
Und dann überrede ich jemanden,
ey, geh doch auf genau die Achterbahn.
Bist du Ingenieur? Weißt du, dass diese Schraube zum Tod führt?
Nein, aber
das könnte man dann gucken. War das eine begründete Gefahrensituation? Könnte man dann gucken. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so wahnsinnig legal ist. Das steht in jedem Gesetz steht, naja, ob das jetzt wirklich niedere Beweggründe waren, das muss man dann halt gucken. Müssen wir dann mal schauen. Das klingt in Latein natürlich immer besser, aber im Grunde heißt es das. Müssen wir mal gucken. Müssen wir mal gucken. Müssen wir mal schauen, dass wir mal richtig gucken. Wir müssen auch gucken, was wir bis nächste Woche machen, denn wir werden euch vermissen. Wir werden euch nicht vermissen. Wir haben uns so an euch gewöhnt, die letzte Stunde, wir haben uns so gut verstanden mit euch. Ihr wart so tolle Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer. Glauben wir. Vielleicht auch nicht. Nein, ihr habt nicht geschwätzt, oder? Hat jemand reingerufen? Nein. Hat jemand Handyang gehabt? Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Hat jemand Handyang gehabt? Der wurde nicht geschwätzt. Das habt ihr schon gut gemacht, wir waren zufrieden. Und deswegen würden wir uns auch sehr, sehr freuen, wenn ihr nächste Woche wieder mit dabei seid, wenn es wieder heisst, das Podcast Ufo öffnet Tür und Tor. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Stefan und Stefan. Ich hebe ab, ich weiss nicht, was du machst. Auch.
Okay, wunderbar, dann hebe ich gemeinsam ab.
Mach Fenster zu, aber sonst haben wir wieder das Druckproblem oben.
Das Hoch- oder Tiefdruckproblem.
Je nachdem, lass uns heute mal ...
Wir heben ab.
It's a Walls-Buy-Production.